Oh my goodness
Wow
I got a homemade bag of thermite a map gas torch and a can of soda .mn .n.because today we're doing science
So here's the basic idea behind this experiment today
We've got thermite and we've got cans of Soda
Now cans of soda Soda are actually pressurized vessels and the more you shake them the more the pressure
builds the soda can itself is a pressurized container made of
Aluminum very thin aluminum and filled with a liquid that's infused with Carbon dioxide gas
The more you Shake it the more pressure rises and the warmer the soda the harder it is for carbon dioxide to stay in solution
The melting point of aluminum is around
1,200 degrees Fahrenheit and with thin aluminum like this it can be melted down pretty quickly now on the other hand
Thermite burns at four to five times that temperature
So it should easily cut right through our can so what is most likely to happen when the two materials meet is the can going?
To explode well the soda shoot like a guys are high up into the air will the whole thing melt
That is what we're about to find out
If you take any standard soda can and flip it over you're going to see some kind of a concave shape on the bottom
We're going to use this as a dish to pile up a little mound of thermite
so when we touch it off all that hot molten iron will flow down to the bottom eat through the aluminum and go straight into
The soda so we're going to do a series of three different experiments here. We're going to start with one
Can that hasn't been shaken at all a second can that has been shaken very vigorously and a third can where we've opened the soda
And allowed it to go completely flat let's get started with cat number one unshaken turned upside down and ready to be lit off
and on the pan
Nice little pile right there
So our Canada said it's got a nice little amount of thermite on the top
So we're going to do now is take a sparkler and light the tip touch it off and run away
Here we go
Wow
That's really broken come check this out
What I noticed just happened is the thermite made a very clean cut out of the bottom here went down in the soda
Obviously burn some of the bottom here because it's float or did it
if we look underneath here the can hot
Not too bad
Looking down at the top of the can you can see there's a hole there in the top
Where the thermite came out and leaked soda all around there's a little bit of the tab that got melted off
Just cuts cut clean in half and we've got a nice little
Bit of slag or something built right up here, so that's a pretty cool reaction
It wasn't nearly as dangerous as I was expecting nice little spark a nice little flare the thermite you could see melted the hole
Right through the bottom and drop straight down to the soda. Which is very cool, but it wasn't very dangerous
I mean the spray radius wasn't very big so let's go ahead and shake up a count soda and see if that has any effect
once the thermite cut through
Just do a little bit less first-time
Sparkler
That was cool interesting so that was a little bit different guys. It actually happened
so fast my Sparkler still going
But check this out when that pops through you can see a jet of soda shot up into the air the thermite didn't make it
Through this time because I put about half as much so it actually like coagulated on the top here
And I I can actually hear something sizzling and bubbling inside
It sounds like there's still quite a bit of soda in that can if I'm to touch it
It's not too terribly hot it's warm actually it is really warm in a top down
Here's not so bad though, and it's still full of soda
So if I turn that over you can actually see that fill out now if I set this down in the soda
Nothing. I was hoping to hear it fizz or pop or something that nature
So interesting so we've got a little bit of damage there. You can see that
Thermite has solidified or maybe that was the aluminum
I think that's part of the aluminum can actually bubbled up the top
Because you can see it's actually part of the can we blistered the aluminum on the can
This is probably where the thermite went in we saw that little yet, so this next cam
Let's do the same thing again, but let's add more thermite
So it actually does get down inside and see if that's a little more explosive reaction
Alright, it's lit a little bit more firm out here, whoa?
oh-ho
Wow, okay, wow, okay?
Okay, okay. We got to talk about this because that was a little bit dangerous look at my glove here
You see that hole in my glove, okay?
When that exploded it sent showers of Sparks of thermite that landed in my hair
And I can now smell burning human hair which is my hair which is a risk
I was totally prepared to take for you today, but that was a little bit dangerous
you can see what happened is once the thermite actually got inside the can it erupted and it took all that Molten thermite on the
Top and sprayed it out into the air some of which landed on me
Thermite is not the kind of stuff if you wanna have stuck to you, so hopefully we got it off
I'm sure you can see little burn marks on my lab coat and if we look around for damage
I definitely thought that land in my hair I
Smelled a little bit of burning, but I think I got it out quick enough
So I think we're good look at how the bottom of the aluminum. Can here is bubbled back up
It's even hard to see where the thermite went in I mean. There's not really any noticeable hole there
We turned upside down though there are two points of impact
It was almost like a cat launching Molten thermite in my general Direction
For this next experiment. We're going to grab a new can pop the top and shake it around
So it loses its fizz and see what thermite does when it goes into an unpressurized can
That's really warm
Since this is an open hole. I think we can go a little bit bigger
Whoa? Oh my goodness. Oh my goodness
apparently thermite reacts with soda
interesting I
Wasn't really expecting that
Just for fun. We have to open up a new can and see if it does the same thing
busy
Just to put a little bit of thermite down in there
Wow, that's quite a reaction that
was just a little bit ah
I wonder a thermite and root beer is the next two mentos and coke
I think what I'm going to do is just try and light one and see if it spills over to light the other
Wow
very cool
Now what's still going? It's actually burning the can and you can actually see the soda boiling
That was interesting actually like melted off the whole top of the can like the aluminum itself was burning
I think it was I think the aluminum itself was brewing this
jumped over
Burned off the top of the can and then the soda itself was actually bubbling there for a little while while the Molten iron cooled
down
Wow, look at how red this soda turns out
Looking how red that is
That is not natural
Wow, okay?
So a couple of interesting things that we just learned here apparently if you add thermite to root beer
It has the same kind of crazy
Reaction that mentos and coke do in fact it might even be a little bit more vigorous that might be something we try to feature
Project the other thing it was really interesting to me is the top of the can itself actually started to burn the aluminum
Just wasn't melting it was actually burning until it dropped down into the liquid and fizzled out now
We have six cans of root beer left. So for one final experiment for one grand finale
I say we stack them up in a pyramid and cover the whole thing with thermite watch them all go off at once
Maybe someday Joe building go home
I'm going to use all the rest of my thermite on this as well
ha ha
Here we are
The pyramid of thermite doom and the question is if I light at the top here
Will it make enough of a shower of sparks to ignite the rest of it? We've got thermite around the base
We've got thermite at every level. We've even got dust coating of thermite on the cans themselves, so grand finale Epic finish here we go
Alright time for Big Bertha. Let's light it up
Beautiful whoa? Oh my goodness
ha ha ha ho oh
My goodness look at this look at this. It's still spraying out under high pressure there
Look at this it's shooting out like 6 feet these little bits are shooting out
This is extremely hot right now if I were to get my glove much closer would start melting
Wow, wow wow?
That looked insane it started with the top and just as I was hoping that Molten
Waterfall spilled over the edges igniting all the thermite at one and when I was a little bit concerned about it
I actually saw the whole thing explode. I saw Molten metal
Go flying through the air a little bit concerned about you mark my camera guy because you right in the line of fire
I'm glad to see you're okay and look at this. This is amazing. We've got bulges on the side of the can here
We've got a little pinhole leaks. We've got these things sizzling. This can is split in half. Oh, wow look at that
How did that happen how how did that happen that's amazing?
This one's still spewing soda
is actually still pretty full for the most part if I shake it and
The you can't set it back down because it will fall over
There's just a tiny little hole on the side here everything else is mostly intact. Oh
Wow, the pull tab is gone this one is full in fact. It's still pressurized to look at look at the way
It's bulged up here the bottom has involved is all whoa
Did you see that?
Did you see that? It's just off that thing is ready to go?
I'm going to kind of open that very gingerly
There we go like a hot one
How's it taste? Yeah? Is this still good can we still drink it?
Hmm. Oh
Man, it's warm. It's really warm. I guess that's one way to get a little iron in your diet
All right guys. Let's take just a second to talk about what just happened there
So we started out this experiment mainly just to see how thermite would react with soda
We tried a series of three different experiments the first one was just a regular soda can when the thermite actually hit that it burned?
The top off completely and fell into the can it was cool that the entire top burned off
But what was even more amazing was that the thermite?
Trickled down to the bottom and burned holes in the bottom of the can as well allowing all the soda to escape the second experiment
Was with a can that we shook up violently and used half as much thermite what we found was that the thermite burned a small?
hole into the top of the can releasing a geyser of soda and
Splashing thermite off to the side so we took another can of soda shook it even harder and loaded up with twice as much thermite
and that one exploded with a bang so much molten thermite got thrown up into the air that actually came down and landed in my
Hair which is not an experience. I can recommend trying yourself
we opened up the next can of soda and sprinkle a thermite around the top where a little bit leaked in and we found the
Geyser reaction that happens between coke and mentos very interesting and when we lit it off
The top of the can actually burned it didn't just melt the aluminum. It actually burned for our last experiment
We used the last six cans to build a pyramid we covered the whole thing in thermite and lit it off to see what would
Happen and happen
It did the whole thing exploded viewing Molten metal up into the sky and raining down all over my camera guy mark
So what really happens when thermite meets soda well it depends on the condition
We're dealing with a lot of factors here from temperatures pressures boiling liquids dissolved gases and burning metals. Which is epik
So there we have a guys another day of epic experimenting nobody got seriously hurt, and we get to live to tell another story
Thanks for joining it for this video. I'll be looking for here the next one Doc you then?
You okay mark? Yeah?
nope
Hey guys, I want to jump back in for just a second to invite you to come follow me on Instagram
I've got a very active page where I post daily pictures and stories the behind the scenes and every day's an adventure
Just take five seconds right now to click the link in the description to come follow me on Instagram at the king of random
I'll see you there